who's hungry
steep dams
my name is george moats and it's my job
to protect the american hamburger at all
costs even oddballs like this one you
ready for this today's lesson is all
about the steamed cheeseburger from
central connecticut steamed hams this
isn't just jesus christ
let me know you're done over there you
good
this isn't just original cheeseburger
people this is a hyper regional
cheeseburger it exists only in a
20 mile radius in the geographic center
of connecticut
i've seen burgers smoked poached deep
fried
but i have yet to find a method as
bizarre as this one
it's because of this
this is a custom made steam box
specifically made for steaming
cheeseburgers that's it you'll find
something like this at ted's restaurant
in maryland connecticut one of my
favorite places to get a steamed
cheeseburger over a hundred years ago
connecticut was the industrial epicenter
of the united states creating things
like firearms clocks
silverware it all came from connecticut
back then
this makes sense
cheeseburger is in a box
steep hams you have a chamber underneath
that holds water
this whole unit goes on top of a stove
and then steam is generated that flows
through the box look at that
cute little trays for beef
and the same size for cheese when the
burger comes out of here it looks like a
gray wet sock for sure don't judge this
burger now i'm fully aware that not
everybody has
a steaming box hanging around their
house like i do
so i'm going to show you a cheat for
making a steamed cheeseburger at home
you ready for this
it's a multi-stage
steaming pot
for making steamed cheeseburgers at home
let's do this making burgers with
water but you can have a single stage
stockpot it's probably easier to have
multiple stages i have a stockpot that
has oh cool insert here
cool insert there
holes everywhere
for the steam to go through the cheese
they use in central connecticut for a
steamed cheeseburger is a secret
from what i understand but i do know
that you can just use regular
mild white cheddar to get as close as
you possibly can
here we go okay let's have some fun
actually first of all let me get this
thing out of here
yay
yay
hang on there we go okay
we're not putting the beef into small
trays i had to make a big patty you're
gonna want to salt it for sure before it
goes into the steamer
and the salt is just gonna melt on there
you'll
and
see
put it into
our steaming
pot on the bottom section in it goes
the big ass patty cover it up
keep an eye on it 10 to 12 minutes go in
and check and if you get a little bit of
give just a little bit you're done the
cheese into the steamer on the top
section or next to the burger if you
want let me explain what's going on in
here scientifically now when you make a
burger
there is the presence of
airborne carbonic compounds which is
basically fat that has exploded and is
now landing back on the burger to flavor
that burger you don't have any of that
going on in here what you do have though
is you have beef steam beef steam
beef steam is a real thing
the more
rendered beef fat that goes into the
water and then becomes airborne inside
this container
makes the burger taste that much better
beef steam
beef steam it's a great name for a band
we all beat steam thanks for coming
tonight if you go to this restaurant
they use a very sturdy kaiser roll soft
on the inside hard on the outside and
they also hand slice all their rolls i
think it's amazing
so first thing first on the bottom a
slice of raw onion on the crown of the
kaiser roll we're gonna put our
combination of mayonnaise
mustard and ketchup now
you see what's happening here when it's
combined with everything else in here
it's almost like a deconstructed special
sauce so that's okay i don't mind that
too much
yeah but i have to do that anyway
then a slice of tomato some lettuce they
use green leaf lettuce and pickles
it does
it looks so gross there's my
my dripping wet
oh so beautiful looking
gray matter burger
steamed put this down first
on my
setup bun there
then this gets a little tricky here
people
there you go see that
got a good grip on this thing [ __ ] go
wrong here
okay
here we go
you have to get make sure you have a
good grip on this thing man oh yeah
oh
it's look at that
what could be better
than hot molten
cheese right
oh
i smell that
and we have
oh glorious look at the
look at the glorious drip look at that
look at the drip of cheese in there
this is pretty hot but i'm going to eat
it anyway
mmm
oh it's so satisfying
it's a hot mess
i love it
it's so beefy
and all i really want when i eat a
burger
is to taste beef
[Music]
i don't know
why
this burger never left central
connecticut
but i do know
that they're lucky they're in
connecticut they're lucky to have this
long live the steamed cheeseburger
make it so
[Music]
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here